Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I’m going to explain an American
science fiction thriller film called “The Signal"
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts as we see a man named Nic,
who suffers from some kind of muscular dystrophy.
Nic is with his girlfriend, Haley, and their
best friend, Jonah, in a car, driving to California.
The boys are dropping off Haley, who is moving
to California for further studies.
The three were all classmates at MIT before
this.
A montage of the trio travelling follows.
They eat at diners, visit aquariums, we also
see Nic jogging to a river that has swiped
away a path.
The trio is staying in a hotel room for the
night.
Nic cannot seem to fall asleep when he suddenly
gets a text from a man named Nomad.
Nomad is an anonymous hacker who has been
texting Nic and Jonah for a long time.
He once hacked into MIT’s server as Nic
and Jonah, and almost got them expelled.
He has been troubling them ever since.
When Nic threatens to expose him for hacking
into MIT, Nomad sends him a live video of
themselves in the exact position they are
in.
He had hacked Haley’s laptop in the background
and is watching them through its webcam.
Nic then takes it upon himself to find Nomad’s
location, and eventually finds out that Nomad
is texting them from Nevada.
They continue the journey from the following
day.
On their way, Jonah receives a picture of
their car from Nomad.
The three are tense about the situation.
Jonah in the backseat actively tries to find
Nomad’s exact location.
They stop at a gas station and Nic gets out
to get them coffee.
Haley takes this opportunity, to ask Jonah
if Nic has said anything about her moving to him.
She knows that her decision to move to California
has bothered Nic, but is worried because he
hasn’t said anything about it yet.
Nic falls and drops the coffee on himself,
while the other two run to help him.
He is embarrassed about his disability, and
it is evident when he walks away to get more
coffee, visibly sad.
The boys have found Nomad’s location and
figured that he is only 180 miles away from them.
They have decided to pay him a visit on their
way, but when they look around, they see that
Haley is missing.
Nic finds her sitting on a cliff nearby.
The two finally talk about their relationship.
Nic doesn’t want his disability to hold
her back, so he wants to break up before she leaves.
Haley tries to convince him that it will work
out.
When he doesn’t listen, she takes off the
necklace he had given her as a gift and throws
it away.
The trio then makes their way to Nomad’s
location.
They stop at an abandoned house at night,
but they are skeptical about Nomad’s presence
at such a place, but the boys go in to check
anyway.
They look around with their flashlight, but
do not find anything.
Suddenly they hear Haley scream outside and
run to her.
When they get to the car, she is missing and
the car’s radio is glitching.
The guys start to panic and scream her name.
Just then, Nic flashes his light in a direction,
and sees Haley being pulled to the sky by
a weird force.
Frightened, they run towards her, calling
her name, the screen abruptly goes blank.
When Nic wakes up, he is in a hospital-like
facility, wearing only a hospital gown, and
is still hazy.
A man in a white space suit-like attire brings
him to a room in a wheelchair.
Another man in the same attire introduces
himself as Dr. Wallace Damon.
He starts to record their conversation and
asks him about the first time he encountered this signal.
Nic has no idea what he is talking about.
He asks Damon about his friends and why he
is here; Damon replies that Nic and his friends
have come in contact with an EBE, an extraterrestrial
biological entity.
Nic is still clueless as to what he is talking
about, and demands to meet his friends or
call his family.
Damon stops Nic from talking, when he sees
Nic’s nose starting to bleed heavily.
He is then taken back to the room he was kept
in before.
The following day, the facility workers take
him to the same room again; on his way, he
sees the workers cleaning a strange liquid
on the facility’s floor.
Then he sees Haley lying in a room.
He demands the workers take him to her, but
they do not agree.
He is taken to Damon who says that he cannot
meet Haley at the moment and starts asking
him a series of strange questions like if
he has ten toes, and if he is from the earth.
Damon then asks him about “the signals”,
referring to Nomad’s texts.
Finally, he shows him a clip from the night
they were at Nomad’s.
He zooms into an alien figure in the background,
which Nic is surprised to see.
To his horror, Damon reveals that Nomad was
not just some hacker.
Sometime later, Nic is back in his room when
he hears someone whisper to him.
He looks around the room and figures the noise
is coming from a vent.
It is Jonah hiding from the workers, to come
to talk to Nic.
He acknowledges that something is severely
wrong with the people there and fears they
might be performing experiments on them.
The conversation ends abruptly.
The following day, Nic is with Damon again,
who this time is performing a shape and color
test on him.
Agitated, Nic solves the test in one go and
demands to see Haley.
Damon agrees and takes him to the room where
Haley lies unconscious.
He claims that she is in a coma and promises,
the second she gains her consciousness, he
will be able to speak to her.
From the next day, Nic starts devising a plan
to escape the facility.
He crushes the cracker given to him as food,
and places it onto the keypad to figure out
the password combination of the entrance door.
When he is back in his room, he puts his plan
into action.
He goes to take Haley and ties her bed to
his wheelchair.
Meanwhile, Damon goes to his room and finds
drawings of the facility all over his bed.
They get to know about his plan.
Nic somehow manages to get himself and Haley
to the exit door, but he cannot reach the keypad.
Nic tries his best and even uses the hospital
tube to press in the keys.
However, Damon catches him before he can.
He wakes up next to Haley, who is still unconscious.
While trying to free from the guards, he falls
off the bed.
The men leave when they see him bleeding.
Then, Nic is horrified to see his legs have
been amputated, and replaced by prostheses
made from alien technology.
Damon, who has been watching him through a
one-way mirror, tells him that it is difficult to explain.
He then sends two workers to get Nic, but
his new legs have superhuman strength.
Using them, Nic sends the door flying.
He drags Haley out with him, as it seems that
he can finally walk now.
As he walks through the hallway with her,
Damon follows them and catches them at the elevator.
He calmly explains to Nic that he will only
be able to help him inside the facility, and
if he goes out, he is on his own.
Nic ignores him and runs away with Haley.
He ends up in a dimly lit hallway and then
in a sewer-like system.
When he finally sees sunlight, he finds himself
in a desert in the middle of nowhere.
Haley finally wakes up, and the two start
to walk away.
After a while, they are delighted to see a
car coming towards them and ask for a ride.
The driver is an old delirious woman named
Mirabelle.
Throughout the journey, she acts strange,
talking to “tiny angels” that she claims
are sent by god.
She drops them off at a gas station.
Nic goes in and tries to use a phone but it
doesn’t work.
He sees his face on the news on the TV, but
just then, Nic sees a red truck take Haley away.
Using his new legs, Nic runs as fast as the
truck.
Haley points a gun she found in the car at
the man trying to kidnap her.
The two throw the man out and drive his truck
away.
Meanwhile, Damon sets a roadblock to look
for the two, and finds Mirabelle.
He asks her to come with him and she agrees.
Damon also carries a mysterious red briefcase
in his hands.
He interrogates her at the facility but strangely,
Mirabelle’s nose starts to bleed like Nic’s did earlier.
Damon brings out a gun from the briefcase
and the screen goes black, implying that he
shot her dead.
Nic and Haley, on the other hand, reach a
dead end and have no clue where they are.
When they drive back, they find an abandoned
visitor centre.
They decide to stay there for the time being.
Inside, Nic tries to use a phone but it doesn’t
work either.
Haley then finds a map of the place, however,
Nic cannot decipher where they are.
Damon and his men continue with their pursuit,
and find Haley’s abductor in his home.
He seems to have gone insane, and talks about
his family sitting beside him when he is alone.
He points a gun at Damon but it doesn’t
work when he tries to shoot him.
Damon then shoots the man dead, covers him
with a blanket, and leaves.
Meanwhile, Nic and Haley hear a noise from
downstairs and hide.
They come across a worker from the facility,
but it turns out that it is Jonah.
The friends finally reunite and share their
experiences, it turns out he also escaped
from the facility.
At night, Nic notices a mark on Haley’s
back and believes that she has been experimented
upon too.
Later Jonah tells him that they might be in
area 51, and we get to see that his arms have
been changed into prostheses.
The following day, they drive in search of
an exit, but are caught in a roadblock.
Jonah attacks a guard and fires some rounds
using his gun, while Nic and Haley crouch
down by the truck.
Soon, Jonah is severely wounded.
He tells Nic to take Haley and go while he
distracts the guards.
Nic doesn’t want to leave his best friend
but has no other way.
Jonah uses his new arms to destroy a cylinder
blocking the truck, and the other two run away.
He then punches the ground creating a shock
wave that shakes the guards.
He dies in the encounter, but it all goes
in vain as Nic and Haley are soon caught by Damon.
Their truck hits a spike line on the road
and flips over.
The two come out of it, but are severely injured.
Haley hands Nic the necklace that he thought
she had thrown away.
The guards take Haley away in a chopper.
After she is gone, Nic notices Damon’s name
tag, and figures that his name backwards is Nomad.
Damon comes clean, and says that he has been
Nomad the whole time.
He had brought Nic to them, posing as Nomad
to test alien technology on him.
He then claims that his legs are examples
of a perfect combination of human and alien technology.
Realizing that they were used as mere experiments,
Nic is agitated.
His legs start to glow red, and he runs at
supersonic speed.
After a while, he crashes into an invisible
barrier that leads him to a larger exterior facility.
Damon approaches the hole he has created in
the environment, and takes off his suit to
reveal a robotic head.
As it turns out, he and everyone else in the
facility are a robotic alien species.
Mirabelle and the kidnaper were abducted humans,
who were driven insane because their brains
couldn’t sync with the alien technology.
Since they could not adapt to it, Damon had
to kill them.
When Nic turns around, he sees that he is
on a whole new planet.
The desert was just a simulation to trick
them into thinking they were still on earth.
The camera finally zooms out, and we see that
the planet is highly modernized with several
skyscrapers and has a parabolic sun shield
on the top.
Nic is the only human there, his best friend
is dead and his girlfriend has been taken
away from him.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.